si vous aimez l'univers des smartphones
et que vous recherchez un smartphone qui
se pli vous aimez quand ça SELI clac
claque c'est pratique vous avez raison
et bien il y a un smartphone qui est
cool c'est celui-là pourquoi parce qu'il
est extrêmement fin je me suis fait
avoir tout à l'heure en préparant la
vidéo vous savez moi j'ai plein de
téléphones à la maison j'en trouve plein
j'ai pris un téléphone standard
classique et je le prends et en fait gen
mais non c'est le Honor Magic V2 et le
Honor Magic V2 il est vraiment est
vraiment surprenant pour ça c'est par
cette finesse il est tout fin c'est très
déroutant qu'on le prend en main je dois
vous le présenter aujourd'hui on va
regarder ce Honor Magic V2 qui est le
successeur du Honor Magic vs et celui-là
ça emmène au nord dans l'univers des
smartphones pliants mais beaucoup plus
loin mais tellement beaucoup plus loin
au-delà de la boîte qui est très jolie
alors je vous montre je sais plus
comment elle souv elle souvre comme ça
regardez à l'intérieur on prend on ouvre
on a la petite languette tac au nord
c'est joli tac on prend ça tac on
regarde ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur c'est
sympa c'est mignon on a une petite coque
de protection qu'on metaria bon je vous
le passe très rapidement parce qu'on on
va pas faire un très gros focus
accessoire aujourd'hui non ce qui nous
intéresse réellement c'est le smartphone
en lui-même et ça c'est génial parce que
si vous aimez je vous dis une fois de
plus les smartphone qui se SP vous allez
être vraiment mais vraiment vraiment
surpris par la finesse par l'épaisseur
qu'on a sur ce Honor Magic vs une fois
de plus je le prends en main je dirais
comme n'importe quel smartphone un peu
plus classique c'est-à-dire qu' ne se
plie pas et bien là pour autant j'ai une
préhension qui est absolument incroyable
et une sensation de finesse pourquoi et
bien tout simplement parce que
aujourd'hui c'est le smartphone pliant
le plus fin au monde en tout qu c'est ce
que Honor nous raconte et c'est vrai que
c'est bleuffant parce que fermé il fait
9,9 mm et lorsque vous l'ouvrez
seulement
4,7 mm c'est extrêmement fin c'est
vraiment tout fin tout fin tout fin et
ça je vous assure que c'est un truc qui
me plaît qui me bluffe mais
énormément parce que quand ce format de
smartphone est arrivé on l'a vu
notamment je vous dis avec le Honor
Magic vs plein de gens se disent moi
j'aime bien ces écrans qui deviennent
plus grands j'aime gagner de la place
pour ma productivité pour le
divertissement pour regarder des films
et des séries vous avez raison mais pour
autant des fois c'est un petit peu épais
j'ai pas pas envie d'avoir un truc trop
épais à la fois dans la main mais bien
évidemment dans la poche on n pas envie
d'avoir un énorme truc dans la poche et
c'est à ça que le Honor Magic V2 vient
répondre ça cette problématique là qu'il
vient répondre aujourd'hui en étant un
smartphone extrêmement fin donc si une
fois de plus vous aimez et vous
recherchez ce type de format et bien
avec le Honor Magic V2 vous êtes
tranquille parce que ça ne prend pas
plus de place qu'un smartphone dit
classique et c'est la même chose avec le
poids 231 g alors bien évidemment c'est
pas comme les smartphones plus léger du
marché mais sur un smartphone Premium
avec ce format là 231 g c'est pas du
tout déconnant alors vous me direz ok on
VO le résultat c'est bien mais comment
est-ce que Honor est venu faire pour je
vais dire quelque part miniaturiser ou
réduire des composants tellement plus
fin qu'on puisse les les introduire sans
aucun problème dans ce smartphone là
bien en fait il y a quelques éléments
qui sont venus réduire en taille à
commencer par la batterie alors c'est
marrant parce que on garde ici une
batterie de 5000 mamph c'est quand même
assez grand une fois de plus s' il les
faut he parce que pour l'écran extérieur
vous me direz bon bah c'est normal c'est
classique ça me va c'est pratique par
contre pour l'écran intérieur on a un
plus grand écran et on se dirait bah
c'est normal il faut une batterie ici de
5000 mahh ok aucun problème et bien en
fait ce qu'ils ont fait c'est qu'ils
sont venus utiliser une nouvelle techno
au niveau de la batterie c'est une
batterie de nouvelle génération en
silicone carbone aussi fine qu'une carte
bancaire je sais pas si vous voyez une
carte bancaire c'est fin une carte
bancaire c'est pas très gros et bien
c'est exactement la même chose qu'on
vient retrouver ici et ce qui permet et
bien d'avoir une batterie extrêmement
fine à peine
2,72 mm d'épaisseur tout ça se fait sans
perte d'autonomie puisque Honor nous
annonce qu'en laboratoire ils sont
arrivés jusqu'à 10h d'utilisation
nonstop ce qui vous permet d'avoir une
bonne journée d'autonomie sans aucun
problème et pour info vous avez la super
chararge 66 W pour venir recharger
rapidement bloc de charge n'est pas
inclus dans la boîte faut le savoir mais
ils sont pas venus uniquement travailler
sur la batterie il y a d'autres éléments
qui ont été miniaturisés pour gagner en
place dans ce smartphone le système de
refroidissement l'antenne le connecteur
usbc et bien évidemment l'écran et quand
on prend tout ça bout à bout on se
retrouve avec un smartphone très fin
extrêmement fin et qui tient sans aucun
problème dans une poche autre élément
qui est intéressant qui a été vraiment
bossé ici c'est cette charnière c'est
une charnière en titane imprimée en 3D
et Honor nous annonce qu'on peut aller
jusqu'à 400000 ouvertures fermeture sans
aucun problème ici qui veut dire sans
ouverture et fermeture par jour pendant
10 ans donc vous ne craignez pas ici de
venir ni casser votre écran ni casser
votre charnière vous êtes tranquille al
le truc qui a plutôt bien aussi que
j'apprécie beaucoup avec ce smartphone
et bien c'est que vous voyez ici la
pliure de l'écran on la sent très peu on
la sent bien évidemment parce que il y a
une pliure on va essayer de venir zoomer
dessus pour vous le montrer il y a une
petite pliure qui est juste là mais on
la sent assez peu sous le doigt c'est
pas dérangeant il y a aucun problème une
fois de plus lorsquon vient naviguer
comme ça ça me convient bien il y a pas
non plus de compromis qui a été fait au
niveau de l'écran on a une dalle au LED
ltpo 120 Hz donc pour le gaming on a ce
qu'il faut en terme de fluidité on a
également ce qu'il faut si vous cherchez
de grands écrans vous aurez vraiment de
quoi faire à l'intérieur rieur vous êtes
sur du 7,92 pouces c'est du Hed 120 ça
je vous l'ai dit mais à l'extérieur
c'est également du Hed 120 et là on est
sur du 6,43 pouces que ce soit à
l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur vous avez
les mêmes techn surtout de très grands
écrans et puis ce qui est souvent un
très gros point fort don je vous parle
beaucoup au niveau de Honor c'est que
ils mettent beaucoup de technologie à
l'intérieur notamment au niveau de leur
d pour venir protéger vos yeux et ça on
le retrouve une fois de plus ici vous
venez dans le confort des yeux et du
sommeil vous avez plusieurs technos qui
sont vraiment intéressantes la première
ça va être l'affichage circadien ça
ajuste automatiquement la température de
couleur de votre écran en fonction de
votre rythme corporel pour aider à
préparer une meilleure nuit de sommeil
lorsque cette option est activée la
couleur de l'écran devient plus chaude
en fait ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que le matin peut-être qu'on vous mettra
une couleur un peu plus froide pour vous
aider à vous réveiller je conseille de
ne pas passer des heures dès le matin
sur son smartphone mais lorsqu'on se
réveille on rege lactu ou son agenda il
y a aucun problème et le soir ça vient
légèrement plus réchauffer pour éviter
ce côté lumière bleue qui va venir
retarder l'endormissement donc là vous
vous êtes vraiment tranquille autre
point qui est intéressante et bien vous
allez avoir la gradation dynamique qui
va ajuster intelligemment les luminosité
de l'écran afin de réduire leseffort
demandé aux yeux et d'améliorer la santé
des yeux donc en fonction de la
luminosité environnante et bien la
lumière va monter ou baisser pour éviter
que lorsque vous êtes le soir par
exemple dans votre lit et qui a assez
peu de lumière de vous en mettre plein
les yeux c'est pas bon pour vos yeux
c'est pas terrible pour l'autonomie mais
d'abord c'est pas bon pour vos yeux et
puis vous avez ensuite la gradation PWM
à haute fréquence 3840 Hz qui elle c'est
un sentiment en fait que vous allez pas
voir en faible luminosité votre écran va
scintiller c'est pas perceptible par vos
yeux mais va y avoir un sentiment qui va
venir vous créer une fatigue oculaire et
bien lui en venant augmenter ici la
fréquence à 3840 Hz et bien on va pas se
retrouver avec ce sentiment ça sera
bénéfique pour vos yeux c'est vraiment
intéressant donc voyez il y a pas mal de
techno qu'on retrouve sur Honor et que
bien évidemment on a ici dans ce
smartphone pliant le Honor Magic V2 un
écran 1 milliard de couleurs pratique
pour venir regarder des films des séries
sans aucun problème mais ça c'est
chouette la regarder pour venir regarder
du comp contenu vidéo c'est extrêmement
pratique très précis c'est cool d'avoir
ce grand écran bien évidemment le
basculer dans ce sens donc je choisis le
sens que je veux comme ça comme ça je
fais comme je veux c'est pratique très
très bien après je peux venir zoomer on
va venir perdre un peu en contenu mais
globalement c'est à vous de voir moi je
préfère regarder comme ça comme ça je ne
perd absolument rien regardez on peut y
aller hop là doucement on zoome comme on
veut alors après ça s'arrête pas là
puisque Honor a voulu mettre le paquet
et vous délivreer beaucoup de
performance à l'intérieur de son Honor
Magic V2 en faisant quoi et bien en
mettant une puce très performante très
bonne également au niveau de la gestion
de la batterie c'est la puce de Qualcomm
le Snapdragon 8 gen 2 c'est pas la
dernière puce qui est sortie cette année
c'est celle de l'année précédente qui
pour autant soyez tranquille et vraiment
extrêmement bien en terme de gestion
d'énergie et qui conviendra parfaitement
bien donc ici vous avez vraiment aussi
une solution qui est très performante et
très pertinent avoir un très joli
smartphone avec des grands écrans c'est
bien mais on aime aussi faire de belles
photos et là-dessus Honor se moque pas
de vous en vous mettant un bloc photo
vraiment cool avec trois optiques vous
avez un grand angle de 50 mégapixel vous
avez un ultra grand angle de 50
mégapixels et vous avez un téléobjectif
de 20 mégapixel vous venez donc shooter
tout ce que vous voulez voyez x 1 x 05 x
2 x 10 et après on peut monter jusqu'à x
40 bon Dirz vous fois 40 je suis pas sûr
mais on peut le faire on a bien
évidemment de la photo de la vidéo le
mode Film le mode pro plus avec pas mal
de modes différents le timel panorama
ralentil filigran bon ok de la Super
Macro le dual View qui peut être aussi
assez intéressant coucou je suis là
storia scanner un document autre
résolution bref il y en a énormément il
y a également le cliché nocturne le mode
ouverture bref il y a pas mal de
possibilités ici au niveau de la photo
et de la VI vidéo bien évidemment et ça
c'est vachement bien il y a plein de
façons de venir l'utiliser on peut le
plier légèrement on peut l'utiliser ferm
comme ça regardez je peux même vous
afficher comme ça vous montrer
directement alors moi je vous vois je
peux venir lancer des photos lancer de
la vidéo regardez vous vous êtes là
comme ça vous me faites un petit sourire
vous êtes peinard l'expérience logiciel
aussi été réfléchie pour le côté
multitâe et pour le redimensionnant des
fenêtres par exemple on va aller juste
là et on va aller sur Youtube alors
regardez juste en haut à droite vous
allez voir il y a une petite icône et
bien en clique en dessus je vais avoir
une fenêtre flottante que je vais
pouvoir venir choisir donc là je peux
lancer mon contenu si je le veux comme
ça en fenêtre flottante ok c'est
pratique après je peux venir bien
évidemment la déplacer comme je le
souhaite je peux venir également la
redimensionner plus grande plus petite
si je la redimensionne à fond ça me la
mettra en plein écran sinon ça me la
laisse comme ça je venir la mettre à
droite par exemple là hop là je viens là
et ça me la fout à droite très
facilement bon ok si maintenant je me
dis ah ben je la veux pas vraiment à
droite et bien je viens la mettre là je
la déplace hop là je vais la mettre sur
le haut B c'est complètement possible et
là je peux choisir une autre application
par exemple jeis mettre une calculatrice
je regarder le nombre de fois où je
répète les mêmes mots dans la vidéo et
ben ça m'arrive quelque fois je répète
un peu alors je peuxir diminuer un petit
peu la taille là voyez comme ça et là je
peux venir faire mes calculs très très
facilement je peux le faire avec de la
note je peux le faire avec WhatsApp je
peux le faire avec mes email je peux
tout faire l'autre truc qui est vraiment
cool c'est que vous voyez une fois que
je suis là j'ai mes deux applications
qui sont ouvertes donc là je vois que je
vais avoir un multitache mais moi si je
veux garder que ma fenêtre en haut sur
ma vidéo que j'ai fini avec ma
calculette et bien je viens vers le bas
hop PAF termin à dos et là je peux soit
réouvrir une autre application soit
garder celle-là faire glisser sur le bas
et là je deviens en plein écran mais il
y a aussi un autre truc qui est pas mal
lorsque je suis sur ma fenêtre flottante
et bien regardez c'est très simple peux
cliquer juste en haut ici là et là il me
propose des options celle tout à gauche
c'est pour me le mettre en plein écran
ok j'ai compris c'est pratique celle là
sur la gauche c'est pour le mettre hop
là sur une partie de l'écran donc là je
vais l'avoir sur la gauche bon après je
fais ce que je veux je déplace je
redimensionne et compagnie vous voyez
celle-là là c'est la fenêtre flottante
comme j'ai là et celle de droite là le
petit trait regardez hop et bien ça me
la met sur le côté ça c'est quand même
pas mal comme ça je peux ensuite aller
ouvrir autre chose je vous montrer la
calculatrice tout à l'heure par exemple
donc là je peux utiliser ma calculette
et si je veux rappeler YouTube j'appuie
dessus j'ai ma fenêtre flottante ici si
je vais là sur le côté voyez ça me fera
une mini fenêtre comme ça je la mettrai
là le temps de faire des calculs un
petit peu plus complexes ensuite ben ah
elle me dérange de ce côté-là je la mets
de l'autre côté je la déplace un peu où
je veux bon pas là parce que je peux pas
appuyer sur le bouton c'est un peu
ballot je la mets là par exemple et
lorsque je vais venir reprendre mon
contenu j'appuie dessus j'ai ma fenêtre
et après je la mets comme je veux si je
veux la mettre sur le côté venir
partager l'écran avec ma calculette je
peux le faire redimensionner mes tailles
de fenêtre de la même manière ma
calculette qui est là et bien si je veux
la déplacer je peux la déplacer d'un
point de vue logiciel c'est malin
pratique pensez vraiment une fois de
plus pour tout ce qui va être produ
activité au global à la maison au
travail c'est donc un smartphone qui ira
aussi bien pour venir travailler pour
venir se divertir avec un partage
d'écran à l'arrière mais aussi à l'avant
qui peut le plus peut le moins une fois
de plus c'est pratique c'est malin c'est
un smartphone qui tout de suite est
disponible au tarif de
199,90 € directement sur le site de
Honor une fois de plus je vous mets le
lien juste en bas dans la description et
jusqu'au 25 février vous avez une
enceinte Marshall qui est offerte avec
c'est une standanm 3 si vous me
connaissez vous vous savez que j'aime
beaucoup Marshall parce que je vous en
parle très régulièrement stanm 3 c'est
quand même pas mal et ça envoie du bois
alors moi je déjà présenté CIT pas la
standanm 3 CEN est une que j'ai juste
derrière ici c'est la WO 3 design
iconique son légende enfin vous
connaissez l'histoire le truc qui est
intéressant c'est le revêtement parce
que vous avez le même revêtement entre
votre Honor Magic V2 et votre Enceinte
Marshall on se parle ici d'un cuir
grainé végétalien c'est pas du cuir
c'est un effet cuir mais c'est du plus
bel effet et autre truc qui est
intéressant on va voir d'un côté et de
l'autre dans votre smartphone et sur
votre enceinte du Bluetooth 5.3 c'est du
le audio qui viendra améliorer la portée
mais également la stabilité du signal
diminuer la consommation d'énergie et
améliorer la qualité audio on se parle
ici d'une enceinte qui vaut 399 € que
Honor vient vous offrir pour l'achat
d'un Honor Magic V2 donc vous achetez le
Honor Magic V2 vous avez l'enceinte à
quasiment 400 balles qui vous est
offerte totalement optimisé pour la
qualité du son entre les deux donc comme
ça vous êtes peénard vous êtes heureux
ou heureuse et ça c'est quand même très
très cool vous pourrez donc vous la
péter avec une belle enceinte et avec le
smartphone pliant aujourd'hui le plus
fin au monde d'ailleurs smartphone qui
est disponible dans deux couleurs là
vous l'avez en noir exactement la même
couleur que cette enceinte Marchal et ça
ça me plît j'aime beaucoup aussi la
couleur PPRE je trouve qu'elle est très
bien réussie très élégante d'ailleurs
j'ai du mal à faire mon choix entre le
noir que je vais avoir ici et le pourpre
qu'on a là dites-moi lequel vous
préférez vous dans les commentaires si
donc ce Honor Magic V2 vous intéresse je
vous mets un lien juste en bas dans la
description moi ce que je retiens ici et
qui m'intéresse vraiment et bien sur
toutes les innovation qu'on va avoir en
terme de miniaturisation pour venir
diminuer l'épaisseur des smartphones
pliants ça c'est vraiment bien réussi
c'est très très très très bluffant
nouvelle technologie au niveau de la
batterie puis tout le travail qui a été
fait au niveau de la miniaturisation des
composants pour venir gagner en place
dans son smartphone moi je trouve que
Honor a extrêmement bien réussi sa copie
dites-moi ce que vous en pensez
marquez-moi ça bien évidemment dans les
commentaires et puis une fois de plus
s'il vous intéresse le lien est juste en
bas et puis et puis puisqu'on se parle
de Honor je vous ai présenté il y a pas
longtemps le Honor Magic 6 Lite qui est
juste là un smartphone très résistant et
tellement résistant qu'on peut venir
planter des clous avec la vidéo est
juste là vous m'en direz des
nouvelles